when I went to South Africa to give a
lecture right after now Nelson Mandela
had spoken I was beyond inspired and let
me just give you one example of everyone
knows why Nelson Mandela is inspiring
you know having spent so many years in
jail and then gone on to heal a country
which many people thought was beyond
healing but in the audience at Mandela's
speech were many people who were
supporters of the government that jailed
him and perhaps even some of his actual
some of the people are actually running
the government to a jailed and one
person asked a question to Mandela said
tell me how can you speak with so little
bitterness to the people who are
responsible for your oppression he said
I would not wish what happened to me and
my people on any single human being
that's an inspiration and it tells me
that the things that I write and teach
about the way in which I've dedicated my
own life to helping other people in the
cause of social justice is not
idealistic it's practical if somebody
like Mandela can do it surely I who
grown up with far less oppression and he
has has a responsibility to do
as a president um education is not a
business it's a profession it's a
calling but I have to be very savvy as a
businesswoman in running an institution
whose budget is 4.4 billion dollars a
year and whose endowment is now over six
billion dollars a year it's the means to
which the end of grade education is
directed so I spent a good deal of my
time and some of my concern making sure
our health system is doing well
financially and I'm happy to say it's
doing fabulously well financially and I
don't see it as a trade-off between
business and education to put it very
simply business as a means to pursuing
great ends I don't think there's any
anything that I as a woman face as a
university president that a man wouldn't
face except the following there isn't
that I am whether I like it or not and I
like it a role model to lots of young
women I hope not too too many because I
don't think this is a job that too many
people should aspire to do but being a
role model is a wonderful thing and I
think because I'm a woman and because
I'm as a woman not very common to see as
a CEO or as a president I stand out and
I think that's the main the main
difference I mean I'm an optimist so I
see the positive i'm sure there are
people who look at me and say how could
she be a president of the University of
Pennsylvania but I take that as a
compliment